I'm here with Elizabeth Lavin what do
you do here at the Kahn Academy well I
work on the school implementations team
which means that I work with schools
that want to use Khan Academy software
to individualize in their classrooms and
to be really innovative I work with them
to figure out how to make that happen I
also work on lots of different parts the
product and things to sort of start up
we all kind of do everything and what
were you doing before this and kind of
what's kind of like the arc of your
career like what are you what do you
think you were doing going to do when
you were in college and what did you end
up doing and then how did you
essentially end up here sure so I in
college I studied history at Penn I
studied actually intellectual history so
the history of ideas and I focused a lot
on human rights and I really was
interested in still am interested in
human rights and how that term changes
in meaning over time and I thought about
spending my career in human rights in
some way which is very vague realistic
sounds good though idealistic yes but
I'm also kind of vague and after college
I wanted some tangible skills so I went
and worked as a management consultant at
McKinsey where I got to help solve a lot
of really interesting problems so to
work at McKinsey coming out of you you
must have been a pretty good student
like McKinsey they don't you know if you
straight see students they don't
interview yeah anyway so but what was
your thought run because you went from a
very idealistic you know Human Rights
you know save the world to I'm gonna go
you know whisper in CEOs years and tell
them how to run their company you know
what exactly I'm obviously so so what
was the thought problem you know I'm the
kids he's a great company obviously so
what was the thought process of deciding
to do that yeah I guess I felt like
coming out of college I was actually
interesting article recently about this
um in the Atlantic about how a lot of
people go and study these really kind of
esoteric things and then they're like I
don't already skilled let me go become a
consultant or work on Wall Street or
something and learn some skills and that
was kind of true for me I knew I wanted
to solve complicated problems I wasn't
quite sure how to do that and I knew
McKinsey solved complicated problems so
even if they weren't exactly their
problems I wanted
solve long-term I thought it'd be a good
way to get some skills and also to
understand how the world works how the
economy works all these things that seem
kind of vague to me that I thought I
could kind of get a window into and so
what was that experience like was it
kind of was it what you expected yeah I
mean I learned a lot there was a great
education in a lot of ways it was like
being in school cuz every few months
you're learning something new and you're
learning all these different industries
and solving all these crazy problems
that are probably like way beyond
anything I should have been thinking
about a pop point in my life but it was
fascinating and the people were really
smart so I got to learn a lot from them
and you were very young and you were in
kind of rooms with you know heads of
corporations and executives and yeah
it's been pretty neat yeah it was cool
and also kind of scary and weird and
there are times I thought like man video
thanks the base it was great and I
learned a ton but I knew I still wanted
to kind of get back to the problems that
were really interesting to me and
Mackenzie does work on that to some
extent but a lot of what I was doing or
problems that were different than the
ones I really wanna spend my time on so
I thought maybe I'd go get some more
skills and go to law school and as we've
talked about you know I was planning to
go to law school right after McKinsey
and and working on human rights go back
to what I really had wanted to do for a
while and then I heard about Khan
Academy and just sounded really exciting
and you know of course I know embarrass
you but I watch the TED talk I was very
inspired I'm very excited and I heard
that Khan Academy was looking to put
together a school's team to work with
schools and it's not exciting to me and
so you know Here I am what was there
anything uh kind that was good you know
you were on this kind of a fast track
you're Mackenzie who spent what two
three years three years at McKinsey and
actually I saw some of your reviews who
are like one of the most highly rated
person we've I mean Shawn who told me
that play the type of ratings that
Elizabeth gets not very few people in
the kids you get and so you're on this
fast track you're set probably for a
very good law school you know what what
was it just the mission that we were you
know what it's education was there
something like what spoke to you about
about this whole thing yeah I mean it
was largely the mission I think that
mission means a lot to me and knowing
that I could get
morning and work on something that I'm
really excited about well it was a lot
of it but there's also something even
bigger than the mission I mean if
there's anything bigger than educating
the whole world for free I don't know
but I think it was it was getting to
start something new it was this idea
that like how often in your life does
someone come along and say to you be
part of this team that's building
something that doesn't yet exist and
it's not just like sort of different
than a bunch of other things that exist
it's something totally new that's trying
to solve a really really tough and
trench social problem and it's a
start-up and maybe it'll work and maybe
it won't but it's gonna be with a lot of
really smart dedicated people who really
want to make a go of it and that's
exciting and I think that I just felt
like you know I could kind of stay on
the the tried-and-true path and I'm sure
that would have been rewarding in its
own right or I could branch off that and
and try to build something from scratch
with a lot of other awesome people and
try to make a go of it and really try to
solve this problem and I just felt I
couldn't pass up opportunity and and and
you you join it with about seven or
eight months now time we're doing this
interview in in late February of 2012
and and you know is there anything
that's been surprising or just as you
expect it it's you know exactly as you
visualize it while you were about to
leave McKinsey or you're disappointing
what's kind of your your view of things
so far yeah anything could have to have
an amazing crystal ball or something you
know exactly what it would look like I
really didn't exactly know what I was
getting myself into it all but it's been
I fell I live my life it's been really
fun I I've been really happy to be here
I think some of the things that have
been surprising you've just been you
know that the scale of change and the
pace at which we're working I mean I
guess when I joined in July we'd worked
with one school district Los Altos and
we're still working with them but
instead of working with four teachers
they were working with like whole bunch
of teachers in the district about 40 of
them then we have all these other
schools we're working with as well
really that's probably 12,000 oh yeah
it's growing so fast and what's amazing
is like you know we're working really
closely with these schools and that's
great for it for those few schools and
that's what we're really seeing a lot of
the innovation but then every time we
discover something exciting at a school
or working with we can just throw it up
online and then all these other people
around the world can see it and use it
to you or will say oh wow you know it'd
be great if we had exercises on this
topic or features on our site on that
would help schools in these ways and we
can create them with the rest of the
team and then suddenly there's millions
of people around the world who are
benefiting from those so it's just like
really fast rapid movement from having
an idea to making the idea happen to
having it affect a lot of people and I
think that's something that's exciting
probably about software in general but
but especially here where it's like you
know we don't have a way for people to
graph linear equations let's create a
way for them to graph linear equations
oh wow look a million people just have
linear equations and that's exciting to
see and is there anything I mean what
are your hopes you know over the next
couple of years or whatever I mean what
are you hoping to see happen well I'm
hoping that we're going to reach a lot
more people around the world and I'm
hoping for a lot of things I mean as
someone on the school's team I'm really
excited about helping to kind of push
the boundaries on education I think
there's a lot of people in education
who've been coming up with lots of
innovative ideas and wanting to do a lot
of things for a long time teachers
really want to meet the needs of all
their students but they haven't had the
tools to be able to do that and teachers
might have been willing to question a
lot of assumptions in education but
haven't really had the right great tools
to make that happen so I'm excited to
work with those kinds of teachers in
those schools just say like you know
let's get rid of age based grouping
let's throw out all these kind of basic
assumptions we have about a nine month
school year and about students kind of
plodding along from 45 minutes of this
to 45 minutes about why do you have to
have math class separate from the
science class separate from art class
I'm excited to work with schools that
want to kind of break those boundaries
down and see what we can do to make
learning more exciting and more engaging
for students and then take whatever we
learn there and help translate that
through our platform to the rest of the
world so that people who even aren't in
schools like that can still have similar
exciting learning experiences very cool